tendante insérer un article additionnel
avant l'article 15 le titre II a été
précédemment examiné nous venons donc au
titre 3 au titre 3 d'abord 4 amendements
en discussion commune 280 monsieur gay
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre
la décarbonation de notre économie si je
me trompe c'est 70 milliards d'euros
donc il va nous falloir trouver
évidemment le financement pour
décarboner notre économie vous nous
proposez par exemple de mobiliser
l'épargne des Français avec à terme
l'espérance de mobiliser 5 milliards
d'euros on aura le débat tout à l'heure
nous allons vous faire plusieurs
propositions au cours de évidemment de
l'examen de ce texte et on commence par
une idée celle de rétablir l'impôt sur
la fortune mais on l'appellerait l'ISF
vert
alors ça couvrira pas les 70 milliards
on a fait un boulot assez sérieux vous
regarderez trois pages amendement et on
pourrait escompter de suite 5 milliards
d'euros donc déjà on propose d'aller
voir on va cranter on a une proposition
pour trouver 70 milliards d'euros 5
milliards d'euros
pour agir concrètement sur la
décarbonation de notre industrie et pour
en profiter
ce ministre
la suppression de l'ISF ça devait
ruisseler et ça devait retourner
notamment dans l'investissement
productif je voulais savoir si vous
pouviez nous en dire plus et pour nous
dire si ça avait marché et si le pour le
coup ça ne marche pas est-ce que vous
êtes prêt à travailler sérieusement
l'idée d'Annie à sept vert je vous
remercie
amendement suivant monsieur
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je trouve que nos collègues
communistes ont eu une très bonne idée
et une très bonne suggestion d'autant
plus que l'urgence climatique est là
elle est plus violente et plus rapide
que ce que nous avions les uns et les
autres prévus et donc il n'est pas tant
de tergiverser alors l'industrie verte
est un des facteurs de relocalisation
susceptibles de diminuer les émissions
mais ça n'est pas le sol et nous voyons
à l'évidence que le gouvernement a
besoin de trouver des moyens financiers
pour mener ces politiques je rappelle
qu'on estime entre 25 et 34 milliards
par an les financements publics qui
doivent être mobilisés pour amortir les
chocs liés à la crise climatique et donc
70 milliards à mobilisés n'ont pas par
an cette fois-ci pour le volet industrie
verte face à cette somme et face à
l'endettement de notre pays on ne peut
se priver de la taxation des plus riches
d'entre nous qui sont par ailleurs je
permet de le souligner ceux dont le mode
de vie polluent le plus ceux qui par
ailleurs sont les moins imposés et ce
pour qui la taxation serait au final
assez indolore nous avons besoin
monsieur le ministre d'argent vous avez
besoin d'argent pour mener des
politiques publiques d'accompagnement de
la transition et de réindustrialisation
de pays de notre pays c'est pourquoi
nous allons vous proposer en ce qui nous
concerne deux versions de l'ISF
climatique on préfère ISF climatique ISF
vers ce premier amendement correspond à
celui que nous défendons à chaque loi de
finance de longue date il se caractérise
par un système de bonus malus en
fonction de l'empreinte carbone des
actifs immobiliers et des actifs
financiers le deuxième amendement sur
lequel je reviendrai puisque j'ai épuisé
mon temps de parole
concernera au fond une version allégée
qu'on pourra appeler la version Pisani
ferry en tous les cas je vous invite mes
chers collègues face à l'urgence
et aussi à l'injustice sociale à créer
cette ISF qui nous rendent mieux
capables d'agir pour la transition
écologique moi je vous invite à
présenter votre deuxième amendement dans
la foulée comme ils sont en discussion
identiques et en disant comme une
très volontiers madame la Présidente
alors comme rarement sur les sujets
financiers le gouvernement a une
tendance naturelle à suivre les
propositions des écologistes rarement
mais ça n'est pas à jamais nous nous
sommes dit qu'il serait peut-être sage
de prendre un amendement de replique et
au fond une réécriture de la proposition
de Madame mafouze et de Monsieur Pisani
Ferri leur propos était assez clairs ils
ont dit au fond l'endettement
inutile et très dangereux mais
l'endettement climatique est très
nécessaire la réindustrialisation que
vous prenez fait partie des
investissements indispensables si nous
voulons mettre fin à cette crise
climatique et donc ça suppose de trouver
une trajectoire de croissance qui
soutiennent uniquement la croissance
utile à la préservation de la
biodiversité de la durabilité et qui à
l'inverse lutte contre toutes les
croissances de dépenses brunes de
dépenses soutenant les systèmes
capitalisant sur le pétrole le
patrimoine financier des 10% les plus
riches de notre pays pourraient ainsi
être taxés à hauteur de 5 milliards
d'euros par an pour financer cette
transition écologique comme le dit
Monsieur Pisani ferry cela il faut faire
en 30 ans ce que l'on n'a pas été
capable il faut faire en disant ce que
l'on n'a pas été capable de faire en 30
ans Monsieur le Ministre BECHU m'avait
répondu il y a une semaine ici que c'est
le Mama fouz et Jean Pisani Ferri
indiquent également que les mesurettes
et les symboles ne sont pas la hauteur
de la marche à gravir monsieur le
ministre il ne s'agit pas de mesurer ni
de symbole dégager 5 milliards pour les
projets de réindustrialisation seraient
bienvenue nous vous invitons à le faire
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre le ministre nous allons nous
aussi vous présenter un certain nombre
de mesures pour trouver des nouvelles
des nouvelles recettes cette amendement
du groupe socialiste vise donc à lui
aussi à rétablir une imposition de
solidarité sur la fortune pour financer
la transition environnementale et le
verdissement de notre industrie il
répond en cela aux aspirations je tiens
à le souligner aux aspirations
des Français qui sont favorables à plus
de 75% à une telle évolution fiscale la
suppression de l'impôt sur la fortune
qui fut l'un des marqueurs un fort du
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
n'a pas eu les effets c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire sur les effets
comportementaux escomptés sauf bien sûr
il a privé l'état de 5 milliards de
recettes chaque année il convient donc
de revenir sur cette mesure car il est
nécessaire
plus doté de recettes renforcées sans
pour autant se placer dans une logique
de hausse généralisée du taux de
prélèvement obligatoire ni dans une
perspective confiscatoire nous proposons
donc un rééquilibrage de notre fiscalité
à deux niveaux en renforçant le poids de
la fiscalité sur le patrimoine et en
mettant davantage à contribution les
plus aisées de nos compatriotes cette
mesure ne parviendra pas à elle seule à
rééquilibrer un système fiscal devenu au
fil des ans de plus en plus injustes
mais il contribuera et devrait permettre
de dégager 5 milliards d'euros de
recettes pour financer une réelle
transition environnementale car comme
nous l'a rappelé le GIEC nous ne
disposons plus que de trois années l'or
est donc à l'action et pour agir il faut
se doter de recettes conséquences
conséquente pardon la mobilisation de
l'épargne privée ne suffira et bien
évidemment pas
merci quelle est la vie de la Commission
sur ses amendements
merci madame la Présidente alors sans
surprise c'est un avis défavorable même
si tu souligne l'important travail du
groupe socialiste qui nous a déposé un
amendement qui s'affine à chaque texte
où nous avons l'occasion de parler du
rétablissement de l'ISF mais pour autant
ça ne va pas changer ma décision et je
sais pas si vous avez lu hier une
interview très intéressante du
gouverneur de la Banque de France alors
certes c'était donné dans Les Echos mais
qui dit qu'en fait notre problème n'est
pas tant un problème de financement de
l'industrie verte qu'on a l'argent à les
disponible c'est l'argent de l'épargne
privé et d'ailleurs tout l'objet de ce
texte est d'essayer de l'attirer vers le
financement de cette industrie mais ce
dont on pourrait bien manquer c'est en
fait de projet éligibles à ce à ce
financement qui dort et qui attend donc
je suis pas sûr que le rat de
sablissement de l'ISF qu'il soit
climatique ou pas soit un bon signal
envoyé à ses investisseurs en fait qui
sommeillent en chacun et chacune qui
dispose d'une épargne sur un compte ou
un livret qui aujourd'hui dort entre
guillemets et si je veux peut-être pour
préciser si jamais il souhaite redéposer
un peu plus tard des améliorations
peut-être à apporter aux amendements qui
ont été déposés par le groupe par
Monsieur Bruyer d'une part c'est que
différencier en fait les taux selon la
comptabilité pardon des placements
soulève quelques petites questions de
contrôle donc il faudrait y penser et
sur votre amendement de repli je suis
désolé et j'aurais certainement
l'occasion de le répéter plusieurs fois
cet après-midi mais plusieurs exemples
dans l'histoire assez récente nous
montre que des prélèvements qui ont été
institués comme temporaires finalement
deviennent des prélèvements durables
juste un petit exemple assez RDS
quelle est la vie du gouvernement sur
ses amendements merci madame la
Présidente je vais faire une réponse
peut-être un peu longue s'il y a
beaucoup d'amendements qui qui vont
attendre un peu dans le même sens ça me
permettra du coup d'aller plus vite sur
sur la vie du gouvernement sur les
amendements les uns après les autres
d'abord madame la rapporteur les échos
c'est un excellent journal et je me
souviens avoir entendu Fabien Roussel
dire juste après l'humanité c'est les
échos que je lis donc je ne doute pas
que c'est aussi le cas du sénateur
[Musique]
ça c'est une maxime que nous connaissons
tous mais parfois moins d'impôts crée de
l'impôt
vous me demandiez le bilan du
gouvernement en termes de baisse des
impôts sur le premier quinquennat
monsieur le sénateur gay nous avons
baissé le taux d'impôt sur les sociétés
de 33 à 25% résultant on n'a jamais
autant collecté l'impôt sur les sociétés
en France parce que oui nous attirons
davantage de capital oui nous avons
tirons davantage de projets
d'investissement on collecte aujourd'hui
à peu près 55 milliards d'euros d'impôts
sur les sociétés par an contre 35
milliards d'euros d'impôts il y a 5 ans
je le répète avec un taux qui était 30%
plus élevé bon on a déjà des taux de
prélèvement obligatoires extrêmement
important on a une capacité de
redistribution qui est unique au monde
on est le pays qui redistribue le plus
et le mieux dans tous les pays
occidentalisés et par ailleurs la
rapporteur la bien dit on a beaucoup
d'épargnes privées qui aujourd'hui est
mobilisable donc c'est vrai que ce qu'on
vous propose dans ce titre là c'est
d'aller chercher je dirais l'épargne là
où elle est en mobilisant cette épargne
sur des produits d'investissement vert
sur des projets des produits d'assurance
vie qui sont aujourd'hui parmi les
produits d'épargne
favor français plutôt que d'aller je
dirais inventer un nouvel impôt qui va
accroître certes peut-être de manière
marginale 5 milliards d'euros c'est pas
beaucoup mais qui va accroître de
nouveau les impôts des Françaises et des
Français là où nous privilégions plutôt
une stabilité voire peut-être si tout va
bien une poursuite de la baisse de
manière à mettre la France dans la
concurrence là encore internationale je
pense que c'est important et je dirais
dans la moyenne on est dans la moyenne
largement supérieure avec un modèle
social qui reste extrêmement favorable
donc nous sommes défavorables évidemment
à assez amendements et nous le serons
pour tous les amendements qui décident
d'augmenter les impôts des Français des
Français
merci Madame briquet explication de vote
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
j'ai bien entendu les explications mais
comme ça a été rappelé ce texte
ambitionne donc de dégager 5 milliards
de financement soit à peu près ce que
rapporterait un ISSF climatique pourquoi
dès lors ce privé de cet autre ressource
de financement qui permettrait de de
doubler la mise mais aussi et surtout
d'obtenir une acceptabilité sociale plus
importante le rapport Pisani Ferry a
suscité beaucoup de commentaires mais
s'il y a bien un constat que nous
pouvons tous faire ce sont d'une part
les montants colossaux qui devront être
consacrés à la transition écologique et
que d'autre part cette transition n'est
pas uniquement une question de
ressources mais il s'agit de convaincre
les Français de ce que la charge est
équitablement répartie et c'est un pot
il concourrait largement
monsieur gay bon monsieur gros il y a
les yeux
merci Madame la présente monsieur le
ministre j'entends bien votre remarque
elle ne résiste pas au fait vous dites
qu'il y a déjà trop d'impôts payés mais
vous avez lu comme moi enfin que les
français payent beaucoup d'impôts vous
avez lu comme moi que ceux d'entre nous
qui sont les plus aisés sommes également
ceux qui payent le moins d'impôts et
donc c'est un sujet de justice sociale
en même temps qu'un sujet d'efficacité
il y a là un sujet majeur qui renvoie
aux questions que vient d'évoquer
Isabelle briquet sur l'acceptabilité
sociale des prélèvements et par ailleurs
nous savons aussi que les modes de vie
des plus aisés d'entre nous et ce ne
sont pas les classe moyenne chers
collègues je l'ai entendu j'ai entendu
Bruno Le Maire excusez-moi c'est le 1%
le plus riche de notre pays qui paye de
très loin le moins d'impôts le 1% le
plus riche de notre pays ça n'est pas du
tout les classes moyennes et même les
10% dans lesquels sans aucun doute les
sénateurs nous nous fais deux parties
sans doute de ses 10%, nous ne sommes
pas non plus dans les gens qui ont des
difficultés de fin de mois donc
concourir aux objectifs de réduction de
la dette climatique ne me paraît pas
scandaleux il me paraît même en ce qui
me concerne tout à fait
enthousiasmant parce que la dette
climatique elle ne se rembourse jamais
et que son coût sur les finances
publiques sur les industries sur
l'agriculture sur nos modes de vie ne
cessent de s'accroître il faut donc
aussi aller chercher des ressources
nouvelles nous parlerons tout à l'heure
de la mobilisation de l'épargne des
citoyens français en tous les cas ce
privé de ressources lorsqu'elles
existent et qu'elles ont un rôle non
seulement social mais aussi écologique
me paraît vraiment dommageable
monsieur gay
merci Madame la prison monsieur le
ministre je vous ai pas demandé sur la
stratégie des baisses d'impôts je vous
ai posé une question simple sur l'ISF ce
qu'on nous a dit on va supprimer l'ISF
et ces 3,5 3,8 milliards seront
réinvestis dans l'appareil productif
c'est comme ça qu'on nous l'a vendu donc
je lis c'est un rapport c'est ni dans
les écoles ni dans l'humanité c'est sur
le site du ministère le vôtre
il n'est pas possible de dire si la
suppression de l'ISF a permis une
réorientation de l'épargne des
contribuables vers le financement des
entreprises mais on mesure un impact nul
de la réforme sur l'investissement des
entreprises et s'agissant de l'impact de
la réforme sur les comportements des
entreprises en termes d'emploi et de ma
salariale on observe une tendance
négative avant et forme mais qui ne
semble pas changer depuis 2018 voilà la
réalité c'est que l'ISF les 3,5 à 3,8
n'ont jamais été réinvesti dans
l'appareil productif ils sont partis
dans l'épargne ou dans la distribution
donc ça c'est une réalité et donc on a
une question mais vous venez d'y
répondre et Madame A rapporteur aussi
est-ce qu'on le fait par l'impôt et donc
on mobilise et c'est une question de
justice sociale et notamment sur les
plus hauts revenus est-ce qu'on les
mobilise sur un enjeu planétaire et de
bien commun notamment pour aller des
carboner ou c'est un autre choix mais là
vous venez nous l'expliquer vous allez
mobiliser les pannes privées mais c'est
pas les pannes de tous les Français
c'est l'épargne de moins de 5% parce que
les 6000 milliards qui dorment en banque
ça appartient pas à tout le monde de
façon équitable donc vous allez
rémunérer les 10% les plus riches à des
taux extrêmement élevés pour un enjeu de
décarbonation on sera très loin d'une
question de justice sociale et ce que
nous proposons avec cet amendement et
avec ceux qui suivront monsieur Montaugé
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues je voudrais
profiter de ces premiers amendements sur
la question financière pour demander à
Monsieur le Ministre
quels sont ces chiffres notamment au
regard de ce que
a étudié et annoncer Monsieur Jean
Pisani ferry par ailleurs conseillé on
le sait de du président Macron notamment
lors du mandat précédent et
économiste que j'ai que j'ai toujours
je vais dire lu avec intérêt par rapport
aux chiffres qui ont été évoqué dans la
discussion lui parle de 66 milliards
d'euros par an
jusqu'à 2030 voilà avec 25 à 35
milliards d'euros sur cette somme qui
reviendrait qui relèverait de
l'investissement public
et avec une proposition qu'on s'endette
spécifiquement pour ça et que
effectivement on procède à des
prélèvements temporaires notamment au
niveau des 10% de la de la population
française les plus aisées prélèvements
qui pourraient rapporter
150 milliards d'euros soit 5% des
besoins c'est déjà beaucoup c'est déjà
pas mal voilà et il insiste sur la
dimension de justice sociale et d'équité
justement par rapport à l'effort
financier qu'il est nécessaire de de
produire donc moi je voudrais savoir
Monsieur le Ministre dans ce contexte
d'abord quels sont les chiffres les
chiffres de Monsieur Pisani ferries que
je viens d'évoquer ils vont au-delà
strictement
de la de la transition
énergétique de la problématique de la
décarbonation ils prennent en compte
l'ensemble de la problématique des
transitions mais voilà c'est quand même
le contexte dans lequel on est avec par
ailleurs 3000 milliards de dettes afin
de 2022 donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire quel est votre approche de cette de
cette épure parce que c'est quand même
le cadre de notre discussion
bien monsieur Chantrel
oui merci madame la Présidente on est
vraiment au cœur d'un débat d'une vision
de société je dirais entre entre la
gauche sur les bancs de la gauche et le
gouvernement c'est que quand on regarde
les chiffres ce qui polluent le plus ce
sont ceux qui possèdent le plus donc
nous on part d'un principe simple à
personne qui pollue le plus doit payer
le plus aussi par rapport à la
transition écologique c'est que la
transition écologique ne doit pas peser
justement sur les plus bas revenus on
l'a vu avec le mouvement des gilets
jaunes notamment parce que votre
politique est justement toucher toujours
les plus démunis et ceux qui possèdent
le moins au détriment de ceux qui
possèdent le plus pourquoi y a-t-il eu
une révolte sociale qui n'est pas
éteinte dans ce pays tout simplement
parce que votre politique sont toujours
basées sur les plus démunis et dans le
même temps vous aviez supprimé l'impôt
sur la fortune qui a coûté au budget de
l'État 3.5 milliards par an c'est à dire
si vous additionnez depuis six ans trois
points 5 milliards par an
d'autant plus qu'elles ne sont pas
soumis à l'impôt au même titre que les
autres et ça c'est profondément injuste
merci je ne vois pas d'autres demandes
d'explication de vote alors je vais vous
informer d'abord que sur les 10
amendements suivants je suis saisi de 10
demandes de scrutin public
nous allons donc commencer par procéder
au scrutin public sur l'amendement 280
qui a reçu un double avis défavorable et
sur les quatre amendements suivants je
ne le répéterai pas tout son reçu un
double avis défavorable 280 le scrutin
est ouvert
me demande à voter si c'est vraiment
c'est bon
le scrutin est clos
votre 343 exprimé 343 pour 92 contre 251
nous passons maintenant à l'amendement
le scrutin est ouvert
on ne demande à voter le scrutin est
clos
votant 343 exprimé 343 pour toujours 92
cours contre toujours 251
sur l'amendement 30
le scrutin est ouvert
si vous me le demandez
c'est
ce que vous êtes d'accord pour un même
vote
je demande à ceux qui sont physiquement
majoritaires
tout le monde est d'accord on va faire
un même vote et on fait encore un même
vote sur l'amendement 15 donc
l'amendement 30 est rejeté et
l'amendement 15 est également rejeté et
je donne maintenant la parole à Monsieur
gay pour l'amendement 286 merci madame
la Présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
dans la suite du rapport dont on évoque
tout et tous l'État le rapport Pisani
ferry il y avait une idée assez
intéressante
celle de taxer 10%
10%
de l'épargne
des 10% les plus riches
certainement que vous avez pas pu sur le
ministre avoir le temps de déposer
l'amendement alors le groupe communiste
l'a fait pour vous
ça rapporterait 5 milliards chaque année
et à l'horizon 2030
36,50 milliards voilà toujours dans la
recherche de financement parce que là
vous venez de refuser 5 milliards
l'isfaire très bien donc là on vous
propose 5 milliards supplémentaires
toujours dans l'optique de décarboner
évidemment notre industrie donc écoutez
c'est c'était dans ce rapport plutôt une
idée de bon sens donc on vous propose de
l'adopter
quelle est la vie de la Commission sur
cet amendement
alors il est doublement défavorable
parce que c'est pire que ce qu'on a vu
juste avant puisque là le taux est quand
même pas négligeable 10% sur les revenus
du patrimoine qui viennent s'ajouter à
ce qui est déjà payé au titre de l'impôt
sur le revenu au titre des contributions
sociales donc juste à un moment il va
peut-être pas y avoir assez de liquidité
chez les gens que vous taxer pour venir
s'acquitter du montant donc voilà c'est
vraiment défavorable quelle est la vie
du gouvernement
rapidement le même avis aujourd'hui les
écarts de rémunération en France après
redistribution ils sont parmi les plus
faibles d'Europe soyons fiers de notre
modèle soyons fiers de notre modèle il
est extraordinaire il permet non c'est
pas vrai il y a pas eu jamais eu autant
d'inégalités en France qu'aujourd'hui
monsieur gay je suis pas d'accord avec
vous maintenant il y a eu des il y a eu
des remarques sur des études qui sont
sortis récemment sur le fait que les
très très très haut niveau de patrimoine
ne serait pas suffisamment taxé en
France
regardez le détail non mais c'est 75
personnes mais c'est surtout 75
personnes sur lesquelles on considère
devrait taxer de la même manière des
revenus effectivement touchés revenus du
travail revenu du capital dividende et
des revenus qui sont ce qu'on appelle
des revenus
latent qui ne sont liés à aucune
perception réelle de revenus par ces
gens-là évidemment s'il retire leurs
actions s'ils gagnent les plus-values il
paye l'impôt comme tout le monde quand
on est sur des plus-values ou des moins
valides on paye pas d'impôts moi je
considère que c'est plutôt bien mieux
donc avis défavorable sur cette
amendement que je n'aurais pas déposé si
vous l'aviez pas fait monsieur gay
sur cet amendement je suis également
stressé d'une demande de scrutin public
est-ce que Monsieur gay je vous donne la
parole pour une explication de vote
madame la présente monsieur le ministre
madame la rapporteur franchement
entendre ce discours après deux ans de
covid ou les inégalités ont explosé dans
le pays non mais franchement ou d'un
côté on a les 10% les plus riches qu'on
continue en magasiner des milliards et
des milliards et de l'autre des images
où on a vu des files d'attente devant
les soupes populaires notamment nos
jeunes et nous dire qu'on n'est pas un
pays inégalitaire alors certes pas le
plus le pays le plus inégalitaire au
monde j'en conviens mais quand même dans
ce pays oui il y a des inégalités et à
un moment donné mais vous l'avez dit
très bien l'impôt il est là pour établir
la justice sociale
on propose pas quelque chose de
confiscatoire quand même
10%
10% sur
les 10% les plus riches de leur
patrimoine et bien vous savez quoi même
si on leur empreint 10%, c'est 10 % là
resteront toujours les 10% les plus
riches
et ils ne le verrons même pas passer par
contre pour la communauté nationale oui
c'est une question et justement pour la
redistribution et pour une question de
décarbonée
notre industrie et notre économie
franchement là on n'est pas sur quelque
chose de confiscatoire donc à un moment
donné pas l'ISF pas de taxation on va on
va revenir sur les dividendes on va
venir il faut pas taxer les dividendes
on va revenir mais enfin à chaque fois
c'est une ultra minorité une ultra
minorité qui d'ailleurs
à proportion égale paye peu d'impôts les
gros dans notre pays paie peu et les
petits paigros c'est ça la réalité et
c'est pas autre chose
très bien donc double avis défavorable
sans cet amendement vous voulez qu'on
fasse un même vote même vote et
l'amendement est rejeté avant l'article
15 un amendement qu'il madame monsieur
Montaugé madame briquet
la présidente monsieur le ministre chers
collègues
Emmanuel 33 donc là la question des
sites est sur le pollué et de plus en
plus prégnante dans les opérations de
renouvellement
urbain et cette préoccupation est liée à
la